i don't particularly enjoy dirt and bugs
so having to get thrown into your own
grave was definitely
an interesting experience
[Music]
my name is madison eisemann hi there i'm
israel broussard and i play
caleb and i play rain in fear of rain
fear of rain is about a young woman
desperately trying to hold on to what is
real while constantly battling her
reality which is schizophrenia
and witnesses her neighbor kidnapping a
young child
and her parents who try so desperately
to give her a normal life begin to
question her
actions and so she turns to the one boy
who believes her
who is caleb we're the cast of fear of
rain and we're here to play who's who
[Music]
madison i mean i get pretty scared but
yeah
i'm probably scared more often but i
think you were jumpier
you're always kind of jumpy that's
probably the coffee
yeah we did drink a lot of coffee on set
i vote matty
it sounds like it's a 50 50 split here
yeah i vote is real
[Music]
for sure me yeah i don't i don't know
how i keep tripping into this universe
but i don't like uh
horror too much i well i'm a huge horror
movie fanatic i can't do them
[Music]
i'm scared of the dark i sleep with my
my tv light on
i think i'm scared of the dark because i
watch too many scary movies like i love
being scared i'm a big chicken
but i also don't think horror movies
would be fun if you didn't get scared
while you watch them
[Music]
israel for sure you would give israel
two sticks in like a sandwich and he
could
survive for probably two weeks i don't
know i need a latte in there
when we were filming all of our stuff in
the woods that was rough for me i don't
particularly enjoy
dirt and bugs so having to get thrown
into your own grave was
definitely an interesting experience
probably me yeah i didn't want to say it
but i wanted to say it you definitely
i've just done too many movies with
creepy dolls i think it's becoming a
thing so
[Music]
i do i have a pretty loud scream i don't
think i've ever even heard you scream
if it's a genuine scream it would
probably sound similar to yours
i don't have a manly scream
[Music]
no no israel is is the one
to nail a take and never believe that he
did i'll say that i
i agree with that i i'm not happy unless
everybody else is happy
and everyone is usually happy except for
you but you're fantastic
i kind of want to say madison
for sure for sure me i'm just like a
giggle monster so like whenever i start
to feel uncomfortable in some way i
always laugh and i ruin other people's
takes too it's really not great it's
like harry and i
he would just be right in my face
yelling at me and i just like for
some reason could not hold it in but i
do that in my everyday life like if
someone's gonna yell at me i'm gonna
laugh in their face
but i also like you know we're dealing
with such heavy material it's like the
only way i can
save myself i think everyone else is
just
to crack jokes and have fun in between
harry all the way remember the doll he
left in your
hotel room yes harry for sure wins the
prank award a beheaded doll on top of a
beer bottle
and was it a full wedding dress on it i
walked in and i was
terrified thank you everyone for
watching be sure to check out fear of
rain wherever you can rent or buy
movies